за моєю широкою спиною інші Мери не
мають права ховатися Центральна влада
краде Центральна Лада буде казати ми не
крадемо це краде місцеве
самоврядування питання будуть до всіх і
до мене у тому числі Я думаю що проблема
корупції вона перебільшена ми самі собі
вклали в міські це наратив тому що ми
всі бігаємо І кажемо корупція корупція
корупція зараз нам потрібно працювати а
не казати я міністр А ти мер А я не буду
на тебе брати слухавку або я з офісу
президента якщо ти не маєш впливу на
політику Ти вже не Олігарх ти просто
супербагата людина окрім Господа Бога та
ППО ніхто не знає
цього як живе обласний центр Дніпро та
як керує містом його очільник сьогодні
поспілкуємося з мером Дніпра Борисом
філатовим пане Борисе Вітаю вас вітаю
Доброго дня Яка роль самого Дніпра от в
умовах війни на нинішньому етапі
ну президент про це казав в тому числі
там у новорічному своєму вітанні ну
Дніпро - це становий хребет України Це
дуже потужний військовий промисловий
медичний хаб гуманітарний хаб Дніпро це
місто яке неможливо недооцінити в плані
оборони України то есть фактично ми
знаходимося між трьох фронтів
Слобожанщина Донбас південь І тому через
Дніпро всі потоки логістичні транспортні
тому тому нас обстрілюють постійно
скажемо так ситуація в Дніпрі
безпекова також порівнюючи зараз і на
початку повномасштабного вторгнення як
можете порівняти Ну я не можу казати все
що мені відомо тому що Знаєте є і
військова таємниця і росіяни постійно
працюють вони відстежують всі у тому
числі публічні виступи І знаєте у них до
мене
окрема любов тому що якщо пам'ятаєте
басманний суд города міста Москви мене
об'явив розшук Ну не будемо про
це ну ми дуже потужно посилили ППО і
фактично у тому числі наше місцеве
самоврядування Ми дуже допомагаємо бпо я
знаю про що кажу ми зробили дуже багато
спочатку
війни укріплень і ліній
оборони
це наша експозиція яка присвячена якщо
можна так
сказати війні повномасштабної агресії
Росії проти України Це наприклад хвіст
від російського вертольоту що вони збили
під час повітряної атаки росіян на їх
позиції Ну
також башта від БМП Ну і така
маленька експозиція яка показує скажемо
так як обладнані наші позиції блокпости
та все інше тому Ну отак от працюємо
знаєте як міський голова Як нормальна
людина яка прагне жити мирним життям Я
би не хотів щоб тут находились ці
експонати за весь час повномасштабної
війни дійсно Дніпро дуже опікується ЗСУ
місто одне з лідерів за передачею
пакетів допомоги автівки лідери за
закупівлею Дронів як вдається все це
робити силами міського бюджету і не
збавляти темпи весь цей час скажу так що
якщо всі так територіальни громади
допомагали Як Дніпро та інші міста не
хочу казати наприклад Хмельницький або
ну не хочу казати щоб не порівнуюватись
з тим хто військове ПДФО дійсно
використовував на бруківку та інші не
потрібни зараз під час війни речі я вам
скажу Так що ми витратили в будь-яких
витратах десь 3 мільрди 400 млйні але не
це не тільки там вантажівки обладнання
дрони та все інше дуже багато ми зробили
в плані
укріплень цього На жаль уряд та Мінфін
не бачить ви згадали міста які на вашу
думку недостатньо допомагають ви
спілкуєтеся з їх очільниками можливо
якось мотивуєте щось змінити чи можливо
це змінити яко ну спілкуюсь але знаєте я
завжди казав і вашим колегам також Це
дискусія дрони проти стадіонів Це
по-перше морально-етичний вибір
кожного кожного чиновника кожного
керівника де і кожної людини і у нас тут
сьогодні буде знову ми будемо нашим
оборонцям передавати дуже багато різних
як кажуть ніщтяків але це ж не гроші
міського голови це гроші платників
податків це гроші територіальної громади
тому Я вдячний кожному дніпрянину за за
те що наші ініціативи підтримують і люди
розуміють що це першочергові задачі на
сьогоднішній час тобто на вашу думку
проблема в тому що інші міста передають
менше в тому що менше ресурсу у цих міст
це дуже така довга дискусія і дуже
складна Я думаю що на неї нам не
вистачить часу тому що універсальної
формули не може бути наприклад є місто
Миколаїв там військової частини
були завжди І скажемо так і зруйнування
зовсім інший характер мають і якщо у
Миколаєва заберуть повністю військове
ПДФО це десь близько
45% від доходів міста Ну це фактично
місто повністю
збанкрутує тому Миколаїв - це окрема
Історія є міста на заході України де
розташовані бригади які там сплачують
військове ПДФО але там немає не
руйнувань і туда поїхав бізнес
ірелоканти і все інше І
вони зараз співчувають себе дуже добре
тому Ну у нас є така корпоративна етика
між міськими головами ми скажемо так не
критикуємо і не обговорюємо друг друга
але якщо казати про таку загальну
тенденцію Я вважаю що місцеве
самоврядування мало і має можливість
більше допомагати збройним силам за моєю
широкою спиною інші Мери не мають права
ховатися скандали ось ці та про те що
бруківка в в центрі столиці там якісь
стадіони нові озеленення також в Харкові
була історія в Дніпрі які роботи
проводяться не пов'язані з військовими
для підтримання життя міста якесь
озеленення я вам скажу який був у нас
скандал я зразу казав хлопцям які цей
тендер оголошували що буде скандал і
сказали Ну не робить цього Ну вони
вивісили департамент наш рекреації е це
підігрів сходів в центральному парку
Щось я не пам'ятаю там 600 000 грн щось
таке Ну але просто люди забули от знову
повітряна тривога Ну ми вже звикли але
люди забули що фактично на цих сходах
кожного кожної зими буквально кожного
тижня особливо літні люди падають
ламають руки ноги навіщо асфальтувати
дороги але от Зараз ми асфальтуємо
внутриквартальноні дороги нуно там де
ями по коліна і туда просто не може
приїхати карета швидкої допомоги Це ж
потрібно робити тобто винятки ви
вважаєте все ж таки мають бути Ну 100%
100% тому я кожного разу повторюю при
кожному спілкування що це скажемо так
проблема морально-етичного вибору і при
тому цьому знаєте неможливо зупинити
життя пане Борис Розкажіть що у вас за
такий куточок з сувенірами Якщо так
можна правильно назвати ну це не
сувеніри це подарунки військових ще
підкреслюю з 14-го року тому
що якщо ви пам'ятаєте то Дніпро став що
в 14-му 15-му
роках проти Новоросії і
фактично в Дніпрі в Дніпропетровської
області сценарії Росії по створюванню
так званої Новоросії він був зламаний
це можна не казати це бюс це пана
Андрійовича Бандери це подарунок також
від
хлопців 24 лютого ми всі прокинулися
зовсім в іншій країні зовсім
інші у нас і наративи і ну ну повністю
все догори дригам перевернулося тому Про
це можна довже довго казати І знаєте
мені часто задають питання стосовно того
що кажуть Ну от же жні Дніпро - це
російськомовне місто у вас там є якась
там Ностальгія по дружбі з Російською
Федерацією я завжди казав що Дніпро - це
не місто яке мріяло про дружбу з Росією
ну це прапор зрозуміло підпис Валерій
залуж це вже за часів повномашштабної
війни дару в яких відносинах ні ні ні в
яких я вам скажу Так що ми з ним
зустрічались один тільки
раз перед війною а Так я працюю і дуже
дуже плідно спілкуюсь з командуючим ак
схід генералом тарнавським та
командуючим сухопутних військ
Олександром станіславовичем сирським Ну
ви повідомляли під час попевномасштабної
війни що дуже змінилися кардинально
відносини з очільниками деяких міст
зокрема з мером Кривого Рогу Олександром
вілколом а в минулому він був ваший
опонент на виборах і від партії регіонів
був депутатом в опозиційному блоці
членом я яким чином проявляється ваша от
ось ці відносини зараз Ну давайте Так
Саша був не просто депутатом від партії
регіон він був віце-прем'єром і я як
завжди казав коли він був віце-прем'єром
у нього ну така корона вирісла на голові
що чіплялася за Я не знаю Мабуть за
люстру я скажу Так що Зараз ми
спілкуємося кожного тижня тому що можна
порівняти наприклад
е по людському
індустріальному будь-якому потенціалу
Дніпро і Кривий Ріг Ну ми безумовно
крутіше ніж Кривий Ріг але це дуже-дуже
потужне місто і е скажемо так і
ментально ну це наші наші брати
зрозуміли І знаєте коли ми приймаємо
деякі управлінські рішення потрібно їх
синхрозувати наприклад відкривати школи
чи не відкривати очна чи дистанційна
коли починати опалювальний сезон і щоб
людей не підбурювати
щоб і прибрати скажемо так цю історичну
конкуренцію яка завжди була між кривим
рігом та ще дніпропетровськом тому що
зараз немає Ну я не знаю ментально може
є Кривий Ріг город дуже я його поважаю
він такий дуже суворий дуже потужний і
Люди там дуже такі суворі і потужні і
дівчата дуже гарні а от ось тут у вас що
знаходиться така окрема кімната та що
кімната що можу показати
що чи доводиться вам ночувати в офісі
скажу От так Ну колись доводилось Да так
доводилося Ну що так знаєте я у кожного
чиновника це дрони да це ми скажемо так
НЗ бувають такі ситуації коли
звертаються до мене напряму комбати і
кажуть Ну слухай ну нема вже Дронів
зовсім і просто я от беру зі свого НЗ і
передаю
його яка роль мерів міст у ці ці
реальності повномасштабної
війни я вважаю так що у і не тільки я
вважаю я дуже багато спілкуюсь з
іноземними дипломатами і не тільки з
дипломатами і з різними відповідальними
особами
з наших країн-партнерів і вони вважають
що Україна вистояла тільки фактично тому
що Україна дуже потужнона всегда була
сильна горизонтальними зв'язками і роль
місцевого само урядування у ції е
повномасштабної агресії ще історія буде
оцінювати тому що якщо би не було такого
потужного місцевого самоврядування
такого народного єднання то
Е знаєте було б дуже багато проблем як
гадаєте ви зі своєю роллю мера впоралися
в цей час
ну Особисто я вважаю що так але мені
потрібно щоб давала оцінку територіальна
громада наші містяни
але нарікань я не чув поки що минулоріч
у соцмережах ви напряму зізналися що
дійсно ви багато спілкуєтесь і
іноземними партнерами і серед них ви
назвали подругою Вікторію спарц члена
палати представників Конгресу США першою
жінкою українського походження До речі
на цій посаді Як ви реагували пізніше
після вашої цієї заяви на її
неодноразову відмову голосувати за ті чи
інші ініціативи на підтримку України ну
Дивіться це дуже складна тема я вам
скажу Так що я би Не хотів її
коментувати тому що Знаєте зараз для нас
дуже
важлива підтримка двохпартійна
і якщо ви звернете увагу яким чином
реагує в тому числі там наш МЗС і
фактично
а скажемо наші посадовці то вони також
це не коментують тому що політика
особливо напередодні виборів
президентських в Сполучених Штатах вона
в Штатах дуже складна і тому я задавав
їй питання Чому вона це не робила і вона
мені відповідала і відповідала і я
розумію чому це не суто проти підтримки
України це скажемо так нюанси бюджетного
процесу в Сполучених Штатах і у них
постійно йдуть дискусії голосувати разом
або окремо або в єдиному пакеті і це
дійсно на допомогу Україні має в
Але якщо ми будемо лізти та коментувати
знаєте ми можемо розбити скажемо так
стосунки у тому числі з нашими
симпатиками Ну я знову же я не хочу
коментувати наприклад наприклад ситуацію
відносини з Польщею Але я вважаю що Ну
десь в наших коментарях або в наших діях
Ну нам потрібно було трішечки трішечки
бути спокійнішими розумієте тому що і
суспільство і польський політикум був
дуже перегрітий тому зараз не хотілось
би перегрівати у тому числі політиком
американськи даваючи свої пояснення І
викрикуючи що це От такі що зараз вони
були стали ворогами України це в
будь-якому випадку це не так ну Вікторія
спарц досить активно коментувала і іншу
тему внутрішньої політики України
зокрема вона висловлювалася щодо
керівника офісу президента пана Андрія
Ярмака називала його публічно проблемою
України зараз в цей момент ви поділяєте
її думку Ну Слухайте Я з Вікторією спарт
зараз не спілкуюсь уже декілька місяців
Ну коли вона це сказала як ви
відреагували для себе от ну це є
приватна думка скажемо так я ж не
прес-секретар Вікторії спарц Ну а Щодо
себе ви от пристаєте на її бік чи
вважаєте інакше Так слухайте я Борис
Філатов я ж не можу приставати до
Вікторії спарц або не до Вікторії спарц
Я маю свою думку що зараз не на часі в
будь-якому випадку обговорювати те про
що ми спілкували з вами на вулиці
будь-які політичні фігури давати їм
оцінку тому що от після перемоги будемо
сваритися і давати оцінку
кожному хто Що робив і бу був чи він на
своєму місці все думаєте нам багато про
що буде
сваритися слухайте У нас така країна Я
вже про це казав що
фактично фактично Я думаю що після війни
і пойдуть взаємні звинувачення тому
знаєте
е в будь-якому
випадку я можу оцінювати і деякі дії
деяких керівников на свій розсуд але це
все буде після війни тобто питання
будуть Да 100% так а питання будуть до
всіх і до мене у тому числі тому що
Знаєте по-різному можна також сказати
куди ти витрачав кошти а як ти їх
витрачав це же знову повертаючись до
того що ми казали питання
морально-етичного вибіру Які у вас
наразі як у мера Дніпра відносини з
офісом президента як охарактеризує
абсолютно робочі я вам скажу що після
того як змінили Тимошенка на кулебу
то я це повторюю ще раз то есть
Тимошенко мог не брати слухавку там два
тижні три тижні місяць чи більше Олексій
Володимирович відповідає зразу і я
вирішую якісь проблеми які є у місни не
у мене особисто і він допомагає це
робити От вчора я спілкувався з новим
міністром оборони рустемом умеровим Я
знову же не хочу казати чого Тому що
були проблеми скажемо так з поставками
деякого обладнання знову же там з нашими
іноземними партнерами я рустму
зателефонував він сказав давай мені
листа Все ми будемо працювати ніяких
проблем то есть беруть слухавку і
роблять це тому що за зараз нам потрібно
працювати а не казати я міністр А ти мер
А я не буду на тебе брати слухавку або я
з офісу президенту таке Ну це це зовсім
не потрібно державі як гадаєте чи
потрібні от зараз в стані війни в
Україні президентські і парламентські
вибори про які вже точаться дискусії Я
вважаю що не на часі чому Ну я не хочу
обговорювати аргументи аргументи всі
відомі купа переміщених
осіб є проблеми з підра хункам і як
скажемо
витримати безпреривність виборчого
процесу ми все це розуміємо якщо росіяни
піднімуть наприклад ці міги з з
кинджалами що ми будемо робити Я вважаю
що зараз це не на часі Тому що під час
будь-якого політичного процеса почнуться
знову чвари почнуться знову вияс
стосунки
і я дуже побоююсь що це може використати
Російська Федерація як гадаєте чому так
активно про це почали говорити саме
західні партнери це з їх боку почалися А
я вам скажу що я не впевнений що це
західний партнер от я вам скажу як
людина яка 10сь років вже при владі от У
мене є таке враження що дуже часто
знаєте є якийсь меседж який проходить по
колу і повертається до тієї людини яка
сама про нього і сказала
от моє отут
і або скажемо так наша там місцева
регіональна Влада там військова
адміністрація обласна рада там всі інші
вони це не обговорюють вони просто
працюють от кожного разу коли ти
приїжджаєш до Києва кажуть А що там з
виборами Я кажу Да ми зовсім це не
обговорюємо от зовсім колишній очільник
Дніпропетровської Ада ваш екс-шеф і
відомий український Олігарх Ігор
Коломойський наразі під вартою і
звинувачують його в шахрайстві Як ви
відреагували на новину про цей арешт Ну
по-перше він ніколи не був моїм шефом Ну
він був формально моїм шефом коли він
був очільником Ада я був заступником але
в приватному бізнесі коли я працював
адвокатом корпоративним Я ніколи не
працював ПриватБанку і ніколи він не був
моїм шефом тому знаєте коли меня
записують там в якісь там я не знаю там
коло Коломойського або в його команду і
я просто працював як адвокат з не тільки
з ними а з іншими олігархами за гроші це
перше по-друге е Я вже казав про це
публічно Я перший серед чиновників серед
керівників державі сказав що він
абсолютне зло що він як і той цар Мідас
і коли доторкається до чого то ко Мідас
доторкався це перетворював в золото а
він перетворюває це в скажемо в бруд
тому
фактично знаєте у нього була
сакраментальна фраза бери від життя все
Що
все що вважаєш за потрібне але каса
супермаркета попереду Він казав це він
це колись казав в своєму програмному
інтерв'ю декілька років тому і ця фраза
мала відношення до Віктора Михайловича
Пінчука він це казав що от Вітя такий
ский він взять там Кучми і все інше тому
він не розуміє що хоче може йти по су
супермаркету життя - це супермаркет але
каса поперед Ну але так вийшло що каса
попереду оказалась для нього а не для
інших чи чекає така доля на інших
олігархів України а давайте подивимось
от що таке Олігарх от знову же якщо
казати з точки зору політологічної науки
то есть Олігарх - це людина яка має
вплив
на не тільки політику але на
суспільство з маючи дуже багато для
цього різних інструментів це фактично не
тільки гроші це і політичний вплив на
партії політичні це і медійна
составляюча то есть можна лі зараз
наприклад вважати того же Ахметова
олігархом коли він відмовився повністю
від медійної составляючї і в нього немає
представництва в Верховної Раді і я не
вважаю що багаті люди або супербагаті -
це погано олігархи - це зло Але якщо ти
не маєш впливу на політику не маєш
впливу на суспільство не маєш скажемо
так е телебачення щоб на суспільні якісь
настрої також мати вплив Ти вже не
Олігарх ти просто супербагата людини
тобто ця Ера позаду ось цих олігархів
цього образу Я вважаю що так і знову же
Ну це скажемо не тільки тому що там
Влада зайнялася олігархами я вважаю так
що ну після того як пролилися річ річки
крові після
24 лютого догори дри все перевернулося
а також ну якщо так от дивиться Ну а хто
може порахувати зараз збитки Ахметова ви
розумієте що його скажемо металургійний
холдинг в зв'язку з втратою маріополя
він повністю обесцінился То есть немає
ліча немає не азовсталі детек сечас
просто втрачає шалені гроші із-за
постійних
обстрілів тому
ну історично просто зараз знаєте зараз
такий карколомний період злому епох тому
я думаю що до олігархав ми вже не
повернемось якщо до олігархів не
повернемось чому досі іноді повертаємось
до корупції як її
побороти Я вже казав про це корупцію
неможливо побороти робочими групами
створеними з там я не знаю там зведена
робоча група в яку входить
прокурор робітник бепа там уср чи що
якісь інший тільки
тільки процедурою і працюючими
інституціями то есть неможливо щоб
знаєте як про Радянській Владі казали
компанейщина от неможливо це зробити
компанейщино тоєсть тільки щоб працювали
інституції такі наприклад як набу що
потрібно щоб працювали чому зараз не
працюють Ні вони працюють Але зараз в
набу наприклад тільки 200 детективів то
естьсть вони не можуть Даже якщо вони
будуть працювати
на7 вони не можуть бігати і всіх ловити
тому що Ну у них просто фізично не
вистачить можливості а поінше я вам
скажу Ну на це я думаю у нас не
вистачить часу Я думаю що проблема
корупції вона перебільшена вона
перебільшена тому що Знаєте ми не тільки
наших західних партнерів у цьому скажемо
так ну цій наратив вклали їму у міський
ми самі собі вклали вмі це наратив тому
що ми всі бігаємо кажемо корупція
корупція корупція і знову же як це Про
вибори то есть фактично ми Таким чином
просто у тому числі підтримуємо
ті меседжи которые несе російськей іпсол
у тому числі на захід то есть безумовно
корупція є безумовно є проблеми але
постійно я знаєте носитися з з цією якби
ситуацією і якщо ми буде знову же за то
що я казав ми будемо казати Центральна
влада краде Центральна Влада буде казати
ми не крадемо це краде місцеве
самоврядування ми будемо казати Та ні
місцеве самоврядування не краде це краде
обласна влада на самому Ну то есть тобто
фактично після оцих от дискусій ми
розмиваємо в масової
свідомості цю проблему перетворюємо її і
вона починає просто жити своїм життям
все мер кривогорогу Олександр вілку
зізнавався в інтерв'ю ДВ що свого часу з
Москви ми Дзвонили і пропонували гроші
за політичну лояльність до вас були
дзвінки ні до мене не було дзвінків він
мені розказував цю історію він казав хто
дзвонив Ну я ж знову же я за третіх осіб
не хочу казати до мене не було дзвінків
тому що я вам скажу мене що з 14-го року
дуже
полюбляють Я пам'ятаю колись в
14-му-15-му
році я не знаю чому
був цілий тиждень коли по всім
російським телевізійним каналам від НТВ
і заканчує рнтв Показували що я нацист
цитували розказували То есть я під
кримінальною справою в Росії під
кримінальною справою в Білорусі тому я
думаю що вони не звертались тому що вони
розумі вас з Бандери в кабінеті да о так
от е Як ви гадаєте наскільки війна
наскільки кроків відкинула розвиток
Дніпра і України в цілому
Дніпро безумовно постраждало ІІ багато
людей поїхало і економіка впала і я не
дуже задоволений наприклад релокації до
нас приїхало просто 56 підприємств але
це не потужні підприємства тому є купа
проблем але знову же дивлячись на те що
зараз ми перебуваємо скажемо так проміж
трьох фронтів і
фактично після нашої Перемоги після
вихоіду на кордони 91го року я розумію
що буде купа проблем у тих територій які
будуть знаходитися біля кордону з
Російською Федерацією і Дніпро знаєте це
та такой остр острів стабільності
фактично тому я сподіваюсь що все буде у
нас в місті добре У нас дуже працьовиті
люди дуже розумні дуже сміливі
тому я дуже хочу дуже сподіваю і
впевнений в тому що в Дніпрі Все буде
добре а опалювальний сезон і можливі
блекаути є готовність Слухайте ну Ми
готуємося але от Хто б вам що не
розказував Я це казав і прош в минулому
році І зараз окрім Господа Бога та ППО
ніхто не знає цього тому що ми не знаємо
скільки вони накопичили ракет Куди вони
будуть влучати
і головне - це ілюзія і я про це кажу
завжди і кажу містянам це ілюзія що
можна втримати систему на генераторах
коли всі бігають кажуть А чого ви
придбали 500 генераторів 1000
генераторів а не 10 000 неможливо на
генераторах втримати систему її Можливо
втримати 35-ш годин ну неможливо її
втримати при морозів -ну20 Я не знаю там
тиждень чи більше також неможливо
мільйони міста запхати в пункти
незлавності коли закінчиться
війна Я один із перших хто казав що
війна надовга
Але зараз я зовсім не хочу давати
будь-яких прогнозів тому що проблема в
тому що Знаєте хоча можу казати Як
приватна особа Ми живемо в вільній
країні але завжди мої слова сприймають
як людина яка обладає якоїсь там
додаткової
інформації тому що Ну все ж таки хоче
регіональне але я керівник тому я нечу
чу давати ніяких прогнозів я не
маю скажемо настільки багато інформації
Як наше вище
військово-політичне керівництво можу
тільки сказати одне що нам потрібно жити
Кожного дня рішати проблеми кожного дня
жити в новой реальності за те що я казав
і просто кожного дня робити все для
нашої Перемоги Дякую вам за цю розмову
Пане
дякую